the nebula is a sculpture that is going
to be installed at the Hilton Anatole
it's a kinetic artwork it has a top part
which is like a structure and a motor
that pulls on 445 cables these cables go
down to a sort of geometric multi-tiered
matrix that just slowly swims in the
atrium of the hotel it's being
fabricated at gizmo in San Francisco and
this ball can go on to hopefully one
truck and it's gonna drive to Gus
and then we're gonna go there and ends
it's gonna take 17 days to install it
somebody apparently did a model and said
yeah little bit
I don't see any of those people here now
this is this is perfect mark Sabatino
like we're gonna load up this truck like
who knows if it's gonna fit you know
he's just total renegade
felt good to see the peace arrived
safely it was a little sketchy best part
of the the entire installation was the
loading we have Schuyler learning how to
drive the forklift and I don't have the
most experience using corkulous we have
a rough road and we started by trying to
like move the tree this semi-truck
couldn't cut a corner
we're ended up using a giant forklift to
pick up this flatbed 48 books by bedrug
so we took this trailer that was loaded
with our part we're up on 12,000 pounds
of her room and we just kind of lift it
up a little bit shoved it over so the
back end of the truck get around the
corner
they picked it up and moved it through
the trees that was awesome
this is our staging area for undoing the
biggest pieces we're gonna take the four
ring pieces off here with any luck we'll
have a clear shot at the stage straight
through the roll-up door took 24 hours
to load the truck and it took I don't
half day to get it off we've got this
all this space we need to take up we're
up here a little bit separate from the
construction around us and under us and
we could just can't have interferences
and interruptions by the people down
below so so it's just layers of work
Marc and not sure who came up with this
idea of building a another raised
platform the platform wasn't built as
high as it was planned to be built but
time being of the essence
they got halfway through it and realized
it was two feet short if there's a
saving grace the people building the
floor work on their knees and there's
water features and planters and tile
going in and underneath us right now is
a lumen ated environment where people
are still working so it's not like
they're working and having a hazard
overhead but they have to be careful
coming in and out and they can't be
happy there's no way they're happy
we're in the middle of a place where
they're jackhammering concrete cutting
stones cutting wood and standing gypsum
all around us so we've had dust on all
of us in our lungs and on the art piece
noise
limited access and having to negotiate
when and where we can put equipment and
get equipment in and out of here
the structure from the top down is
comprised of some simple named parts the
ring and the truss the ring is made up
of circular rolled tubing with flanges
that connect the sections together
there's four sections and then what
we're calling spokes that come from the
connection points on the four sections
up to a middle hub
to locate on this side of it because we
wouldn't even get doing all that stuff
sits up in that area you know above the
the lower IBS
I wasn't sure from the plan view whether
these yeah
apex top or down ultimately it will it
will Center it will center on this set
of holes or this set of holes etc and
get bolted at four points clockwise
lift them off the ground ain't no half
tones or belief
where's our DTI washer guy
that or do you see the gauge on that
it's the 3/16 of an inch there's a
little extra so we've run into a
situation where our bolts are too short
to pass inspection
the inspection requires that bolt stick
out quarter-inch so we can match the
threads with a chisel it's one of these
safety things where we match the threads
up and they come out they can unscrew
the threads have been deformed so our
bolts are too small we have the entire
ring to repo
turn the corner and there's some new
challenge like the bolt challenge which
was a day and a half of really hard work
every day on this installation has been
a struggle has either been though the
bolts are too small we gotta go get some
more it's been ups and downs at certain
points it's it's going better than I
expected it to but I'm in a pessimist so
I tend to think everything's just gonna
be a disaster then I go okay it worked
thank God and then you turn the corner
and there's some new challenge but it's
pretty interesting when nobody really
knows what this thing is gonna look like
or what's it's gonna if it's gonna work
so there's like this like everybody has
like a real drive just to see what's
gonna happen